we are the detectives of the past and we
have to figure out what happened that is
what is fascinating about archeology
that we super-special archaeologically
because this is one of the cradles of
civilization is where civilization
actually arose from nothing a little
over a hundred years ago here in Bingham
went to Peru and relying on local
knowledge found this crumbling city in
the middle of the rain for us at the
time he used state-of-the-art
photography equipment to record what was
there it was the first scientific
archeological expedition that National
Geographic funded and in some ways that
helped to launch our modern age of
archaeology so the idea of applying new
state-of-the-art technology to map sites
in Peru feels like a natural extension
of what here in Bingham did over a
hundred years ago one of the dreams of
archaeology has always been to look from
above as drones became available five or
six years ago
archaeology jumped at this opportunity
finally we can fly above our excavations
and take a picture that reveals
everything that we have been seen from
below
now if you simply go up up up now into
the space and look down with a cover you
get the same time look at not one square
mile but many square miles and then you
can focus on specific items that you
think are important space archaeology is
the study and the use of satellite
images or mapping ancient archeological
features and environmental features by
looking at different parts of the light
spectrum we see subtle changes on the
Earth's surface caused by what's buried
beneath and what satellites helped us to
do is pinpoint areas and we know to
within a few meters exactly where
something is grow thousands of miles
away we're the generation with all the
tools and all the technologies to be
able to map sites and protect them and
using these new technologies we have a
real chance to protect and preserve
these sites for future generations
[Music]